nous devons donc deux points à l'ordre
du jour l'audition de Monsieur jaffrello
et ensuite le rapport du texte de la
Commission
sur la PPRE les transferts forcés et
massifs d'enfants
Ukrainiens donc pour démarrer cette
réunion j'ai donc le plaisir nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir monsieur
Christophe jaffrello donc directeur de
recherche ou série Sciences Po CNRS et
présidente l'Association française de
sciences politiques Monsieur le
Directeur mes chers collègues le
président Christian Cambon ne peut
malheureusement pas être présent
aujourd'hui il le regrette et en son nom
et au nom de l'ensemble de mes collègues
je vous remercie de venir nous éclairer
ce matin
tant sur les enjeux de la relation entre
la France et l'Inde que sur les enjeux
régionaux j'ajouterai que j'ai le
plaisir de vous retrouver puisque je
préside le groupe d'amitié France
Pakistan c'est pas loin de l'Inde et
c'est même voisin et que nous avons eu
régulièrement l'occasion d'échanger sur
sur ce sujet
depuis 2022 la croissance indienne
devance la croissance chinoise et cette
tendance devrait se confirmer en 2023
les évolutions démographiques laissent
penser que le développement indien sera
alimenté en main d'oeuvre au moins
jusqu'en 2050 l'économie indienne encore
marquée par des retards d'investissement
des lourdeurs administratives notamment
pour être venir le moteur de la
croissance mondiale sa rivalité avec la
Chine risque de s'accroître alors que
les conflits frontaliers entre ces deux
pays sont toujours meurtriers et que le
territoire indien est lentement et
silencieusement gagné par la Chine les
élections de mars 2023 dans l'Utah
Pradesh laboratoire de l'induva doctrine
nationaliste hindoue défendu par le BJP
faisait figure de tests grandeur nature
avant les prochaines élections générales
de 2024 qui pourrait ouvrir un Aran Audi
et son parti un troisième mandat
consécutif la victoire du BJP semble
témoigner de l'absence d'impact
électoral des grands événements de ces
dernières années gestion catastrophique
de l'épidémie de covid au printemps 2021
qui a frappé de plein fouet Luther
Pradesh le ralentissement économique la
crise de l'emploi ou encore le mouvement
massif de protestation des agriculteurs
contre les réformes du gouvernement
maudit vous nous donnerez sur ces points
s'il vous plaît votre analyse votre
expertise la charge contre la BBC dont
un documentaire sur des violences qui
avaient causé en 2002 la mort d'au moins
1000 personnes accablé le BJP et le
Premier ministre indien qui dirigeait
alors l'état du bujara n'est pas le
signe d'un fonctionnement démocratique
des pouvoirs et d'ailleurs des
contre-pouvoirs la mise à l'écart du
leader d'opposition Raoul Gandhi en mars
interroge également
pour contrer l'influence grandissante de
la Chine l'Inde apparaît aux Etats-Unis
notamment comme un allié de choix la
France dans le cadre de sa stratégie
Indo-Pacifique à noué un partenariat
stratégique fort avec l'Inde caractérisé
par des ventes de rafales d'Airbus la
construction de 6e d'accueil les
investissements
occidentaux et l'Occident trouve à
l'espoir de nouvelles possibilités
d'investissement alors que la situation
se tend en Chine le développement
économique on l'a vu une suffit pas à
garantir la convergence vers un modèle
démocratique dont les contours sont
toujours plus flous entre libéralisme et
il libéralisme qu'elle pourrait être
selon vous l'évolution de l'Inde dans
les prochaines années vous nous direz si
vous estimez que ce pays qui a été
longtemps la plus grande démocratie du
monde se projette comme une force de
stabilisation régionale voire mondiale
où faut-il au contraire craindre une
politique pra gmatique guidée par des
intérêts égoïstes comme pourrait le
laisser entendre l'achat massive de
pétrole russe et le refus de voter les
résolutions de l'Assemblée générale de
l'ONU sur la paix en Ukraine je rappelle
que cette audition est captée diffusée
sur le site internet du Sénat sur le
directeur vous avez donc la parole
excusez-moi j'avais pas repéré le petit
bouton merci beaucoup pour cette
introduction et merci de m'accueillir
pour échanger avec vous à propos de
l'Inde effectivement sachant que le
Pakistan est aussi un domaine d'études
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président et que on ne peut pas parler
de l'incend évoquer l'autre dans bien
des dans bien des cas ce que je vais
essayer de faire en pour introduire
notre conversation c'est de
d'observer les deux évolutions que vous
avez d'ailleurs déjà évoqué en termes de
politique étrangère l'INDA beaucoup
évolué je me rappelle avoir participé à
la visite de Jacques Chirac en janvier
98 lorsque le partenariat stratégique
entre la France et l'Inde avait été
nouée on était au tout début d'une
relation qui depuis n'a cessé de se
resserrer et
au cours de ces dernières décennies
connues des évolutions par lesquelles je
commencerai et puis deuxième partie
c'est un plan à la science-pop
la politique intérieure qui
effectivement
évolue elle aussi et évolue dans une
direction qui peut nous inquiéter et
cela tend d'ailleurs en termes de
traitement des minorités qu'en termes de
réduction des libertés alors d'abord
cette
évolution à l'international c'est-à-dire
que l'un des deux venus
un pays central pour notre politique en
Indo-Pacifique et d'ailleurs vous avez à
l'écran la carte que nous avons
construite à Sciences Po nous avons créé
un observatoire franco-allemand de
l'Indo pacifique avec des partenaires
de l'Institut de Hambourg le Guigard et
vous avez une une carte qui vous montre
l'ampleur voilà de la vision que la
France a de l'Indo-Pacifique et la carte
précédente vous montrait à peu près les
mêmes frontières la France est l'Inde
sont les seuls pays à avoir une vision
aussi inclusive de ce qu'elle
Indo-Pacifique ça va de la côte Est de
l'Afrique à la côte ouest des États-Unis
aucun autre pays nous avons fait 12
cartes sur ce site internet montrant les
visions de l'Indo-Pacifique de 12 pays
aucun autre pays n'a une vision aussi
extensive c'est un des points que nous
avons en commun mais
ce n'est évidemment pas suffisant pour
faire un partenariat et ce que je
voudrais dire pour commencer c'est que
ce que l'on a vu au cours des dernières
années c'est un rapprochement non pas
seulement de l'Inde et de la France mais
de l'un des deux l'Occident et ceci
s'est trouvé un peu accéléré et même
beaucoup accéléré par les pressions
chinoises et sur le petit diapositif sur
le petit diaporama que nous ont préparé
si vous remontez au début de la série de
cartes vous enverrez une montrant les
incursions croissantes de la Chine
enzoimalayenne on en parle assez peu on
en a parlé en 2020 lorsque
voilà à cet endroit là au Tibet
ou Ladak qui est la
zone frontalière du Tibet et bien
l'armée chinoise a mené une offensive
dans la vallée de la galwan qui s'est
traduite par la mort de 20 soldats
indiens jamais encore depuis
1967 les échanges de tir et pas que de
tir d'ailleurs et pas principalement de
tir de quoi c'est du corps à corps qu'il
s'agit en fait on est à des altitudes
telles que qui font que lorsqu'un soldat
est frappé blessé tombe dans une rivière
et bien il meurt et ainsi que les vins
soldats indiens sont morts et jamais
depuis 67 on avait eu un bilan aussi
lourd
alors cette pression chinoise je prends
cet exemple on pourrait en trouver
d'autres elle joue un rôle très
important dans la façon dont l'un ne se
tourne vers l'Occident et c'est à la
suite d'ailleurs de cette
échange de cette de ce clash je cherche
le mot français mais il ne me revient
pas que l'INDA accepté de faire que le
quad soit élevé au niveau ministériel le
quad c'est le symbole de se
rapprochement de l'Inde et de l'Occident
et de l'Inde et des États-Unis en
particulier dans l'adopacifique car
jusque là les Indiens avaient souhaité
ne jamais voir des puissances étrangères
dans leur marée Nostrum dans leur Océan
Indien et là la puissance la pression
chinoise est-elle que on est plus que
demandeur de partenariat avec des
Occidentaux à commencer par les
Américains et les Australiens pour
résister c'est le premier changement
absolument remarquable qui nous amène à
comparer un contraster la position
actuelle de la position par exemple
d'Indira Gandhi qui lorsque les
Américains avaient mis un pied à Diego
Garcia avec poussé léocris à l'époque
dans les 70 il n'était pas question que
les Américains viennent dans l'océan
Indien aujourd'hui on les invite on les
appelle et on veut faire le maximum de
choses avec eux avec eux et avec la
France et ici c'est bien sûr de la
France qu'il faut plutôt parler s'il y a
un rapprochement avec une puissance
européenne
aujourd'hui du point de vue indien du
côté indien c'est la France la France du
fait de ce partenariat stratégique bien
sûr qui est très fort mais du fait aussi
des échanges que vous avez évoqués en
introduction et principalement des
achats d'armes la France est devenue
l'un tout premier fournisseur d'armes de
l'Inde il y avait déjà un
héritage rappelons-nous les mirages la
visite de François Mitterrand 1982 c'est
le début c'est le début de
vente d'armes de plus en plus
importantes les scorpen et puis
maintenant les rafales donc on a une
montée en puissance de ce partenariat on
peut le dire stratégique et militaire
qui se traduit aussi d'ailleurs par
des accès mutuels
réciproque à des bases militaires la
visite de Emmanuel Macron en mars 2018 a
permis que les Indiens puissent accéder
à des bases militaires françaises dans
l'océan Indien notamment à la réunion
avec une réciprocité et puis il y a bien
sûr aussi les manœuvres conjointe les
manœuvres Varuna par exemple qui sont
très anciennes et qui permettent à des
appareils à des à des navires
français et indiens de tester leur
interopérabilité le
porte-avion Charles de Gaulle lui-même
est allé dans la zone pour l'une de ces
opérations de
l'exercice si vous préférez et un autre
point important
que l'on ne saurait négliger les
garde-côtes indiens font avec les
garde-côtes français des patrouilles
c'est les seuls qui ne soient pas de la
région qui sont ainsi invités à ce genre
de manœuvre mais c'est que la France
aide la région puisque la France est
puissance résidente de l'océan Indien et
que
l'Inde le reconnaît est considère que
c'est une bonne façon de travailler
ensemble
voilà quelques éléments succin mais
j'espère assez significatif qui illustre
le rapprochement de l'Inde et des
occidentaux les Américains bien sûr les
français aussi
maintenant en parallèle il y a une
continuité avec la politique antérieure
qu'on a qualifié de non alignement
et le non-alignement indien et bien il
se traduit aujourd'hui par le fait de ne
pas prendre parti
dans le contexte de la guerre en Ukraine
alors c'est un positionnement très
ancien qui remonte à la prière puisque
Jawala le nérou Premier ministre de
l'Inde de 47 à 64 avec posé les bases de
cette
attitude refus de prendre parti pour un
bloc ou pour l'autre à l'époque c'était
bien sûr la guerre froide et il y voyait
une violence insupportable ça avait créé
un mouvement le mouvement des Non
Alignés dont la culture est quand même
très
résiliente et on le voit dans le
Canadien mais on pourrait je suis prêt à
revenir à la discussion on la voit dans
le cas indonésien cette culture aussi et
j'étais Jakarta l'été dernier pour
constater que les différences entre ces
deux pays n'étaient pas si grandes
alors on voit quoi on voit
essentiellement un refus de prendre
parti dans les instances multilatérales
contre la Russie
absence de condamnation de l'invasion
russe de l'Ukraine
abstention quasi systématique au concept
de sécurité ou l'Inde a été membre non
permanent jusqu'en décembre dernier
abstention quasi systématique à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies
lorsque la question ukrainienne est
posée et parfois elle est posée pour des
raisons humanitaires et ça ne change
rien ne se prononce pas ne se prononce
pas contre la Russie ou pour l'Occident
comment expliquer cela et ça je crois
que c'est vraiment la culture
internationale de l'un de la qui est à
scruter de près
il y a bien sûr un élément concret la
dépendance militaire de l'Inde vis-à-vis
de la Russie
deux tiers des armements indiens sont
d'origine soviétique ou russe
et il y a bien sûr la
une corde de rappel une hypothèque qui
pèse toujours sur la liberté de parole
et d'attitude des Indiens et c'est
davantage vrai pour l'armée de terre que
pour
la marine mais c'est aussi très vrai
pour l'armée de l'air vous avez certes
des rafales et des mirages mais
énormément de soukoys et puis encore des
Migs
les Russes ont eu cette intelligence de
ne pas vendre trop cher parfois on peut
penser qu'il y a eu du dumping et
surtout de faire de la du
co-développement tu as du transfert de
technologie les Indiens sont très
demandeurs parce qu'ils n'ont toujours
pas d'industrie de défense de transfert
de technologie et là les Russes sont su
faire de la coproduction et pas
seulement d'ailleurs dans les appareils
que je viens de citer c'est les Indiens
et les Russes qui ont développé un
missile la courte portée le brame que
maintenant l'un de la Russie vendent aux
Philippines par exemple donc on est sur
du co-développement de technologie
militaire
l'Inde on veut davantage encore encore
une fois je le rappelle mais c'est très
important voilà un pays qui n'a pas
d'industrie de défense
et non pas réussi à construire une
industrie de défense ils ont besoin de
l'aide internationale extérieure plutôt
pour pour cela et les Russes ont su être
je le répète moins 10 ans et
généreux en transfert technologies mais
ce n'est pas la seule explication de
l'attitude indienne vis-à-vis de la
Russie dire que quand on lit les écrits
du ministre indien des Affaires
étrangère et Shankar qui est vraiment en
charge de la diplomatie indienne j'ai
Shankar parle au nom de l'état indien et
au nom du gouvernement indien avec toute
la légitimité qu'il faut lui reconnaître
et lorsqu'on le lit et bien on constate
qu'il y a qu'il y a deux autres raisons
pour lesquelles
l'un de condamne pas la Russie d'abord
un antioxydantaliste
hérité de l'anti impérialisme on est en
situation post coloniale on n'est pas
sorti d'un état d'esprit qui est
l'héritage de la lutte anti coloniale et
l'anti impérialisme et le mot d'ordre
c'est quelque chose qui en particulier
s'adresse aux Américains mais que tous
les Occidentaux
ont en partage première explication
deuxième explication est peut-être
est-elle plus importante encore une
vision du monde que j'ai chanté qualifie
de plurilatéral c'est quoi le
plurilatéralisme le plurilatéralisme ce
n'est ni le multilatéralisme ni le
bilatéralisme ni le nilatéralisme bien
sûr c'est la capacité de l'Inde de faire
avec des partenaires différents des
choses
qui soient distinctes les unes des
autres on choisit de faire telle
opération avec tel partenaire et puis
tel autre opération avec telle autre
partenaire et plus il y a de partenaires
possibles potentiel dans le jeu plus on
a les mains libres plus on a une marge
de manœuvre grande ça veut dire quoi
dire qu'on ne se lit jamais les mains
avec un allié l'idée d'alliance
d'ailleurs est bannie de l'Inde on n'a
pas d'allier en Inde
on cherche des partenaires mais pour des
opérations qui seront ponctuelles de
manière à avoir le la plus grande marge
de manoeuvre possible et dans ce cadre
dans cette dans cette vision
plurilatérale du monde et bien plus il y
a de pôles plus il y a de partenaires
possibles mieux ça vaut et pour cela
l'un veut une Russie forte elle veut une
Russie forte
parce qu'elle dépend de la Russie pour
ces armements mais elle veut une Russie
forte pour élargir le champ des
possibles de même qu'elle veut une Union
européenne forte une Union européenne
forte c'est aussi important pour l'Inde
parce que ça fait un pôle de puissance
en plus dans le jeu ce qu'elle redoute
le plus c'est le monde bipolaire et
manque de chance
c'est la combat c'est dans cette
direction que que le monde est parti et
c'est une des grandes hypothèques qui
pèsent sur la politique étrangère de
l'Inde c'est-à-dire que elle se trouve
en un sens courtisé par tous
on l'a vu récemment il y a eu un grand
ballet diplomatique suite à l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie tous les pays
ont envoyé des émissaires pour essayer
d'amener l'Inde de leur côté mais comme
elle n'est venue d'aucun côté elle peut
ne pas être seulement courtisée par tous
mais finalement isolé et ne sachant pas
comment gérer la bipolarisation
croissance du monde il y a là un défi
que on va d'ailleurs voir se répéter
au G20 du mois de septembre le G20 du
mois dernier des ministres étrangères à
montrer les limites de de l'exercice
d'équilibrisme que l'un d'essayer de
mener faire un consensus sur la question
ukrainienne ça a échoué Russie et Chine
on fait dérailler cette initiative ils
vont remettre
le couvercle et j'ose dire en septembre
rien ne dit que ça marchera si
véritablement il y a un une
division des puissances internationales
autour de deux ensembles
et sont plurilatéralisme vont avoir des
difficultés de positionnement et là il y
a un défi qui est majeur donc voilà ce
que je pouvais dire sur les questions
internationales et sur la politique
étrangère de l'Inde de manière brève
mais j'espère suffisamment clair
la situation
intérieure
je vais essayer de m'y attarder
davantage parce que je pense que il y a
là pour nous des interrogations qui
doivent faire débat
on a un lien de plus en plus fort avec
ce pays sont toujours savoir où il va et
mieux cerner sa trajectoire
intérieure me paraît vraiment capital
vous l'avez dit en introduction ligne
d'audva le nationalisme indou est
maintenant au pouvoir depuis 2014 et
cela se traduit par une forme de
marginalisation des minorités du pays de
plus en plus préoccupantes le séisme
douce c'est quoi c'est une idéologie qui
a monte aux années 20 de toute façon
un siècle plus tard nous sommes de
retour aux années 20
les années d'entre-deux-guerres ou se
sont cristallisés tellement de
nationalisme
exacerbées c'est une illogie qui
consiste à dire l'Inde est hindoue à
80%, les hindous sont les fils du sol
sont la population autochtone les
minorités les musulmans les chrétiens en
particulier sont des pièces rapportées
qui ne peuvent pas prétendre à un statut
de citoyenneté
donc on crée des citoyens de seconde
zone et les musulmans sont les
principales victimes de cette tendance
qui est à la fois de fait et de droit de
fait parce que le mouvement de la
sioniste hindoue est très puissant sur
le terrain c'est un mouvement qui
remonte à 1925 c'est un des plus anciens
mouvements
de ce type au monde c'est comme si les
différentes chemises de différentes
couleurs qui se sont développées dans
l'entre-deux-guerres en France elle
avait continué à prospérer vous vous
souvenez sans doute que dans les années
20 il y avait des chemises vertes des
chemises brunes des chemises de toutes
les couleurs et bien ce mouvement il a
il a une chemise blanche il a un calot
noir il a un short kaki il a des boots
et puis une arme une arme blanche ça
c'est l'uniforme de ce mouvement ce
mouvement est très puissant sur le
terrain car depuis un siècle il a C de
pénétrer la société alors société très
diverses territoire très étendu nous
parlons d'un territoire qui fait la
taille de l'Union européenne 3 millions
200000 km2 est néanmoins ils ont
pratiquement
implantés leur présence développer leur
présence partout sauf dans l'extrême sud
et
on les a vu développer un syndicat
étudiant un syndicat ouvrier un syndicat
paysan ils sont dans toutes les
catégories de la société avec ce même
discours que celui que j'ai présenté en
introduction
donc sur le terrain ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'il est de plus en plus
difficile pour les musulmans de
pratiquer leur religion pour les
chrétiens de pratiquer leur religion
des églises sont attaquées une liste de
la croix est en train de faire un
reportage qui va sortir pour le weekend
de Pâques et je vous recommande sa
lecture car ce sera du terrain détaillé
et les musulmans sont la cible
principale de sorte que
les milices les groupes paramilitaires
qui patrouille les campus universitaires
qui patrouillent même les villes
empêchent des musulmans par exemple
d'acquérir un logement dans des
quartiers mixtes la ghettoïsation des
musulmans est l'un des l'une des
conséquences de ce processus et quand je
dis ghettoïsation je ne parle pas
simplement du fait que les pauvres se
retrouvent ensemble un ghetto au
contraire par définition on français
c'est des gens de toute classe sociale
qui se trouve qui se retrouvent ensemble
du fait de leur identité et donc vous
avez des musulmans de classe moyenne qui
sont très éduqués et qui ne trouvent
plus à se loger dans des lieux où les
hindous sont majoritaires ça c'est
l'aspect de fait qui s'est traduit aussi
par des violences mais je veux pas être
trop long ceci dit les cas de lynchage
ont été assez nombreux et on fait on
fait quand même la une des journaux
indiens d'autant que les réseaux sociaux
sont là pour les relayer
lyncher un musulman ce n'est pas
seulement faire un mort c'est aussi
impressionner toute la société et toute
la communauté musulmane donc ça passe
par les réseaux sociaux
au point d'ailleurs que Mark Zuckerberg
s'est ému de l'usage qui a été fait de
Twitter ce qui est rare
de jurer des yurets et bien on a eu des
lois des lois aussi qui mettent le
sécularisme indien a rude épreuve l'un
des sinon laïque du moins séculière ça
veut dire que toutes les religions sont
reconnues sur un pied d'égalité dans la
Constitution
mais on voit pour la première fois des
lois qui donnent un hindouisme une
primauté
un exemple le
Citizen ship Act la loi définitant la
citoyenneté en Inde a été amendé en 2019
de sorte que seuls les non musulmans
issus du Bangladesh de l'Afghanistan ou
du Pakistan sont maintenant éligibles à
la citoyenneté indienne
ce qui est en contradiction directe avec
la
lettre et l'esprit de la Constitution du
pays autre exemple au même moment où
presque le l'article 370 de la caution
indienne qui donnait au Japon et
cachemire une autonomie particulière a
été abolie et le Jamo est cachemire le
jambon cachemire qui était un État de
l'Union indienne a été rétrogradé au
statut de théâtre de l'Union et Ladak a
été coupée a été séparée est devenue un
territoire de l'Union aussi
à ce moment là ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que la police de l'État est
maintenant directement responsable
devant New Delhi et non plus devant le
gouvernement de la région c'est un effet
de centralisation et de fait le jeune
week Kashmir et Sud administration
directe de New Delhi depuis 2019
trois anciens chefs du gouvernement de
cet état ont été emprisonnés pendant
plusieurs mois et les élections sont
reportées
de loin en loin
ça c'est l'aspect je dirais purement
ethnique ethnou religieux qui fait que
la démocratie
est mise à mal du point de vue du
multiculturalisme qui était la grande
tradition indienne rappelons-nous le
matmagandi qui était toujours prêt à
défendre les minorités quand elles
étaient attaquées maintenant la
démocratie elle est aussi
mise en difficulté
du point de vue de ce que nous appelons
la tendance à l'île libéralisme
cette idée de démocratie libérale me met
toujours mal à l'aise parce que c'est
une contradiction dans les termes et je
préfère parler d'autoritarisme
électorale on a un système
où les élections continuent à être le
mode de désignation du
chef du gouvernement
des responsables
mais entre les élections on a des
tendances autoritaires qui finalement
rendent l'élection
pratiquement redondantes parce que il
n'y a pas la compétition politique qui
permet que les élections soient libres
et entièrement fiable
que se passe-t-il entre les élections
les institutions de l'État ont été
prises
d'assaut par le parti au pouvoir et
la liste est longue je me contenterai de
mentionner deux ou trois institutions
le central de rock investigation le FBI
indien est maintenant un bras armé du
pouvoir et d'un pouvoir partisan la
commission électorale la commission
électorale qui est censée organiser les
scrutins d'une manière impartiale est
elle aussi peuplée d'amis du pouvoir
plus important le pouvoir judiciaire
partout dans ces pays et je mets l'un de
maintenant quasiment dans la même
catégorie que la Hongrie de Orban la
Pologne de casinski
Israël aujourd'hui partout le pouvoir
judiciaire et la cible privilégié et ce
que Netanyahu cherche à faire
aujourd'hui et bien maudit à essayer de
le faire dès qu'il a pris le pouvoir en
2014 la première loi qui l'a fait passer
le premier amendement à la Constitution
qu'il a fait voter a consisté à changer
la façon dont les juges de la Cour
suprême allaient être nommé c'est
toujours la même chose
la Cour suprême était nommée elle est
encore d'ailleurs je vais vous dire en
quoi par d'autres juges les juges Coop
dans quelque sorte et les juges des
tribunaux des états désigne des juges de
la Cour suprême la loi le changement qui
a été prévu par cette réforme avec pour
objectif de remettre la nomination des
juges à 5 personnes seulement dont trois
responsables politiques il n'y avait
plus que deux magistrats dans le comité
chargé de désigner les juges à la Cour
suprême la Cour suprême a mis un pied
dans la porte et empêcher que cette loi
passe mais le grand évangé en refusant
désormais de nommer les juges que le
collège des magistrats désignaient pour
occuper le poste de membre de la Cour
suprême de sorte que en 2015 2016-2017
on a eu un nombre de juges partis à la
retraite et non remplacé qui a créé une
vraie crise et en 2017 la Cour suprême
s'est résignée
à ne pas chercher à nommer des membres
nouveaux qui n'auraient pas la
bénédiction du pouvoir et donc on est
dans une situation
d'auto-censure de la Cour suprême depuis
maintenant plusieurs années et
aujourd'hui même d'ailleurs un test
intéressant va avoir lieu puisque Raoul
Gandhi a été disqualifié je vais reviens
dans un instant et la course va devoir
dire si disqualifier le leader de
l'opposition qui Raul Gandhi dans les
conditions actuelles c'est véritablement
légal sera-t-elle irathel toujours la
même direction de docilité vis-à-vis du
pouvoir
ou pas c'est un des grands des gros
enjeux mais ça amène au troisième point
que je voulais mentionner l'opposition
à une tâche de plus en plus ardu en Inde
de très nombreux hommes politiques ont
été disqualifiés empêché de se présenter
aux élections
arrêter
et puis on bénéficier de la visite de
d'agents venus contrôler leur
déclaration d'impôts ou autres et toutes
sortes de
raisons les ont mises hors d'état de
nuire ces nouveaux Raoul Gandhi le
leader du principal parti d'opposition
est dans la même situation aujourd'hui
puisqu'il a été condamné à deux ans de
prison
et que deux ans de prison ça l'oblige à
démissionner de son mandat de député
donc il est exclu du Parlement est-ce
que tu Parlement parce que dans le haut
Parlement Raoul Gandhi était la voix qui
était la plus détonnante
dissonante en tout cas et on a donc un
parti d'opposition le Congrès qui est
privé de son leader en tout cas dans
l'enceinte parlementaire et c'est une
atteinte évidemment claire au jeu
démocratique
j'en cite deux autres pour compléter ce
tableau on a des restrictions à l'action
de la presse qui sont de plus en plus
fortes et si vous regardez les
classements quel que soit les
classements vous regardez Freedom House
voire des reporters en France frontières
tous les classements concernant la
liberté d'expression en Inde font
dégringoler le pays dans les vers la fin
de la liste
une des raisons étant que vous avez de
plus en plus la prise de contrôle de
médias indépendants par des hommes
d'affaires proches du pouvoir là on
retrouve le modèle Orban d'ailleurs
exactement
copier-coller toute façon bon c'est une
des choses à laquelle on travaille en ce
moment un Sciences Po c'est les
communications
internes ou externe d'ailleurs entre ces
personnalités qui en fait échangent les
bonnes pratiques et bénéficient de de
conseils de de marketeurs certains
d'ailleurs basé aux États-Unis on a
découvert que ABCO worldware conseillait
beaucoup de ces personnes pendant cité
qu'une alors
la presse les médias notamment la
télévision ont été tellement
mise en difficulté que par exemple le
grand mouvement que Raoul Gandhi a animé
ces derniers mois une marche de 3500 km
de la pointe sud de l'Inde jusque au
jambon et cachemire à à peine été
couverte dans dans les médias dernier
dernier point
parmi les dissidents potentiels
vous avez évidemment les ONG et les
intellectuels et dans les deux cas on
les voit victime de politique très
ciblées les ONG en particulier alors de
toutes sortes il y a les objets
confessionnelles bien sûr les ONG
chrétiennes qui ont tout de suite été
ciblées et ont perdu l'accès aux
ressources étrangères et puis il y a les
ONG
qui sont plus de droits de l'Homme
Amnesty International
deux exemples amis international ne peut
plus fonctionner en Inde
a été empêché de continuer son activité
en Inde compassion une ONG chrétienne
qui depuis 1968 travaillait en Inde à
l'éducation des enfants et 140000
enfants
de toutes les religions profiter de
cette de ces de leur activité
ces deux organes bien d'autres ont perdu
l'accès au fond étranger et n'étant plus
en mesure de collecter des fonds à
l'étranger elles ont mis la clé sous la
porte on est passé de 30000 ONG à une
dizaine de milliers d'ONG aujourd'hui en
quelques années deux tiers de ONG
indiennes ont dû renoncer leur travail
alors que l'un des temps pays de NG s'il
y a bien un pays où ce sont les ONG qui
s'occupent des soins de l'éducation
c'est l'Inde et là on a un vraiment qui
a gagné
les intellectuels c'est d'abord les
universitaires les universités indiennes
ont été pour la plupart
mise en difficulté par la nomination de
nouveaux présidents la grande université
de Delhi Nero University et premier
exemple mais il y en a bien d'autres et
même les universités privées
l'Universités privées qui
pour nous était des partenaires et là je
parle au nom de Sciences Po on avait
quantité de partenaires dans le monde
université privée et bien celle-ci
perdent aussi leur liberté d'expression
et rendre la collaboration très
difficile donc voilà un défi qui pour
nous je crois mérite réflexion nous
sommes devenus un partenaire stratégique
important d'un pays dont la trajectoire
politique intérieure n'est pas
nécessairement celle que nous attendions
et celles sur laquelle nous avions fondé
nos premières actions
je conclus par l'économie parce que
effectivement les graphiques que vous
avez vu défiler
le montrait il y a de grands espoirs mis
dans l'économie indienne d'abord du fait
ça démographie effectivement on a
maintenant avec l'Inde le premier pays
au monde en termes démographique et la
croissance démographique va sans doute
se poursuivre jusqu'à 2050 on travaille
l'instrumental il y a des projections en
ce moment pour essayer justement de
faire de la prospective sur l'Inde et on
se dit que probablement 2050 sera le pic
ça peut être plus tard 2060 ça veut dire
que l'Inde à un énorme potentiel aussi
en termes de dividendes démographique
vous savez ce qu'on appelle des ventes
démographique c'est les 15 49 ans par
rapport aux autres quand la catégorie
des personnes en âge de travailler et
bien supérieur à la
aux autres catégories qui ne sont pas un
âge de travailler alors on bénéficie
d'un dividende démographique
maintenant cette viande démographique il
est tributaire d'une donnée forte qui
est l'éducation car une population jeune
n'est un véritable atout que si elle
était éduquée et là l'un de continue à
ne pas investir dans ce domaine on a des
budgets d'éducation qui restent à 5 6%
qui sont très très bas avec des taux
d'analphabétisme qui restent assez
élevés alors on a plus de recensement ça
c'est un autre élément que les régimes
autoritaires nous ont appris à connaître
il n'y a plus de données statistiques
les recensements qui étaient des scénos
depuis 1880 pour la première fois depuis
1080 le recensement n'a pas eu lieu et
n'aura probablement pas lieu pour éviter
d'en savoir trop bon alors on n'a pas de
données récentes sur le taux
d'alabétisme mais on sait que il était
encore de quasiment 28% en 2011 et c'est
quelque chose qui évidemment mérite
d'être
traité quand on parle de divan
démographique à côté de ça il y a des
fleurons dans cette économie qui reste
les moteurs de la croissance une
croissance vive vigoureuse et évidemment
c'est le secteur du it des technologies
de l'informatique qui sont les
principaux moteurs l'adresse absolument
imbattable dans ce domaine avec de très
belles entreprises
tata consultant si service
we pro qui sont des leaders mondiaux qui
continuent à caracoler en tête du CAC 40
à l'indienne
le point noir c'est l'industrie
l'industrie ne cesse de perdre des parts
de
départ de marché
et ne représente plus guère que 15% du
PNB
c'est un pays qui du coup donne à son
à son profil économique des allures
postes industrielles avant d'avoir été
industriel
c'est les services qui comme dans toutes
les postes industriels
sont majoritaires mais là n'a pas
industrialisé sa société encore et du
coup il y a là un défi que
n'a rien de ramolli pensait relever en
attirant des investisseurs étrangers en
faisant que ce soit des multinationales
qui viennent industrialiser l'Inde c'est
son grand programme make India qui comme
un des graphiques qui figurait sur le
powerpoint le montre ses investissements
étrangers n'ont pas eu lieu
deux points pour conclure sur l'économie
ce que
l'économie politique de l'un nous montre
c'est une évolution vers un système
oligopolistique et ça c'est lié encore
une fois au régime dont on parle
les oligarques les oligarques indiens
sont les grands bénéficiaires du nouveau
du nouveau régime l'un d'entre eux Gao
tamadani est devenu en quelques années
l'homme le plus riche de l'Inde
et ceci grâce aux privatisation
notamment puisque les privatisations
d'aéroports de port lyon-permis
d'acquérir grâce à ses amitiés
politiques des grandes des grands
fleurons des infrastructures indiennes
cela un inconvénient
parce que c'est aux dépens du rôle des
régulateurs et tout récemment il y a
quelques semaines
euh gothamadani a été accusé de mal
versation et son cours de Bourse a chuté
dramatiquement montrant la fragilité de
ce genre de fonctionnement c'est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles la olgandie
est persona au Parlement il était celui
qui systématiquement annoncé les
méthodes de gothamadani l'autre
inconvénient de ce système oligarchique
c'est que il a tendance à fermer le jeu
et les entreprises étrangères ne sont
pas bienvenue car ce sont les
compétiteurs que redoutent ces grands
hommes d'affaires
Vodafone on a fait les frais Walmart on
a fait les frais
ce sont des des des grandes entreprises
Williams par exemple qui ne veulent pas
voir arriver de compétiteur et qui du
coup
invente ou trouve les moyens de créer
des barrières non tarifaires les
bailleurs tarifaires sont déjà assez
élevés mais les barrières non tarifaires
c'est encore plus redoutable parce que
ça veut dire qu'on ne peut pas lutter
avec avec les
dominants locaux et je t'aimerai
là-dessus le protectionnisme et sans
doute l'un des autres problèmes qu'il
nous faut gérer surtout à l'heure où le
ou le ou le traité de libre-échange avec
l'Union européenne est en discussion il
y a deux ans ou presque on a relancé la
négociation sur ce traité de
libre-échange la négociation avait duré
de 2000 à 2013 et elle n'avait pas
abouti on a relancé la négociation sur
Internet libre-échange Union européenne
Inde et les difficultés que l'on
rencontre sont un peu les mêmes que dans
les années 2010 quand on cherchait
encore à faire à faire
le protectionnisme indien
est très et très fort et et de plus en
plus fort de plus en plus fort
sachant que par ailleurs ce qu'il
demande à l'Union européenne est aussi
de moins en moins acceptable par nous
des visas des visas pour des ingénieurs
pour des aromaticiens notamment donc on
a on a nous côté européen aussi des
formes de protectionnisme qui se sont
développées mais sur le terrain indien
c'est une des grandes difficultés
et je terminerai par là
concerne la protection des données
personnelles aujourd'hui quand on fait
du commerce international le
e-commerce notamment implique que les
données personnelles bénéficient de
certaines protection l'un ne veut pas se
doter d'une loi qui ressemble pro à la
rgpd il n'y a pas de loi protégeant les
données personnelles elle préfère
pouvoir garder l'accès à ces données
et cela va compliquer singulièrement la
conclusion de certains aspects de ce
traité de libre-échange ce n'est pas du
protectionnisme là c'est une forme de
implication économique d'une tendance
politique la surveillance des citoyens
doit permettre l'accès aux données
personnelles protéger des personnels
n'est pas l'ordre du jour en Inde
aujourd'hui
nous avons d'ailleurs à la demande de
l'AFD organisée les 12 et 13 juin
prochain à Sciences Po toute une journée
sur ces questions de
Digital India qu'est-ce que une Inde
digitale sans protection des données
personnelles et qu'est-ce que ça
implique pour nos collaborations
notamment au plan économique donc ça
c'est un autre des aspects que on doit
situer au croisement du politique et de
l'économie en vérité voilà je m'arrête
là merci
le directeur merci beaucoup pour
cette exposé à la fois exhaustif précis
parce que non je trouve et inquiétant je
le crois aussi sur ce fantastique pays
qui nous réserve
probablement des surprises voire des
désillusions l'avenir le dira j'ai
plusieurs collègues qui souhaitent vous
poser des questions ce que j'en ai 6 ou
7 ce que je vous propose c'est de les
prendre et puis vous aurez ensuite le
temps nécessaire pour y répondre la
première question c'est Joël guerriot
qui la pose votre voisin merci président
il y a quelques années en 2020 nous
étions avec huxory et puis Rachid temal
dans un groupe qui travaillait sur leur
rapport sur l'Inde qui a été publié en
juillet 2020 et qui porte le titre
l'Inde un partenaire un partenaire
stratégique
donc nous sommes nous étions dans cette
conviction et malheureusement nous avons
été privés du fait de la pandémie de
nous rendre en Inde et de voir plutôt
que d'entendre
mais déjà nous avions fait un travail
qui nous avait permis de mesurer à quel
point ce sujet est majeur pour l'avenir
je dirais même de notre planète le égard
à l'importance de l'Inde et j'aurais
revenir sur un point que vous avez
évoqué que la population de l'Inde à
savoir aujourd'hui un milliard 400
millions de personnes avec une évolution
comme vous l'avez dit avec un pic qui
serait attendu en 2050 qui serait entre
1 milliard 600000 Lyon à 1 milliard 700
millions donc ça veut dire une
population très très importante et
j'aurais parce que vous avez eu un
exposé très très intéressant où vous
nous avez vous avez touché du doigt
beaucoup de sujets je sais combien c'est
difficile de parler de tout puisque il
s'agit là d'un très grand pays mais pour
autant on n'a pas parlé de la population
j'aimerais vous entendre sur ce point à
deux niveaux le premier c'est
sur le plan de la pauvreté parce que si
l'un est un pays aussi important en
nombre c'est aussi un pays qui a le plus
nombreux le plus grand nombre de pauvres
alors qu'elle peut qu'elle avenir
attenddre sur ce pays à travers une
lutte contre la pauvreté est-ce que on
peut espérer qu'un jour les choses
aillent mieux pour cette population
extrêmement
mise à l'écart et les conséquences que
ce même cela pourrait avoir en termes de
révolte de réaction par rapport à cette
situation et surtout si vous vous
évoquez le fait maintenant que les
oligarques accumulent des fortunes alors
même que il y a dans ce pays beaucoup
pas faire par rapport à ces personnes en
difficulté et dans le même ordre d'idée
je voudrais quand on parle de population
humaine aujourd'hui on a aussi toujours
une inquiétude c'est le changement
climatique et les conséquences sur le
changement climatique par rapport à des
comportements qui sont des comportements
évidemment peu propices à l'avenir sur
notre planète alors je voudrais savoir
si il y a des partenariats que l'on
pourrait attendre sur le plan
énergétique sur le plan de développement
durable sur le plan environnemental
entre la France et puis l'Inde sur cette
aspect est-ce que vous pourriez nous en
dire plus eu égard ou également au fait
que nous pensons bien sûr que c'est là
un sujet majeur qu'il ne faut pas
sous-estimer par rapport à tout ce que
c'est passé au travers des relations
internationales vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de pluralisme est-ce que c'est
dans le pluralisme anax sur lequel la
France pourrait être le premier
partenaire merci
merci
François Bono maintenant il y a la
parole merci président
merci également pour votre exposé qui
était particulièrement intéressant et
passionnant
dans la compétition qu'on peut voir
entre l'Inde et la Chine notamment et
que vous avez évoqué il y a
effectivement des des choses qui jouent
en faveur de l'Inde et d'autre part et
j'aimerais vous poser une question par
rapport au système des castes en Inde et
si vous pouvez dire aujourd'hui ce que
ça peut représenter comme comme frein
pour le pour le développement de la
société indienne en parallèle des
questions que que vient de poser mon mon
collègue
merci François Jacques le nez maintenant
oui merci oui votre exposé était très
très complet malgré tout ma question
rejoint celle de joliério quelle
politique en matière de lutte contre le
changement climatique l'Inde mettait en
place cette politique se fait-elle en
coopération avec des partenaires
particuliers ou sur des sujets précis
mais je voudrais aussi savoir quel
regard vous portez sur la coopération
tripartite entre la France les Émirats
arabes unis et l'Inde qui ont été lancé
le 4 février dernier
merci la parole est à j'en aurai Guérini
maintenant
merci président eux ce matin en me
levant je vous ai écouté
dans une radio publique
et vous dites que le premier ministre
Monique venait de commettre une faute
politique vous l'avez pas dit comme cela
il y a quelques instants
l'opposant Candy du Parlement dans le
prolongement de sa condamnation pour
diffamation envers le Premier ministre
pourriez-vous décliner ce sentiment
cette position
alors
qu'il vient seulement d'interjeter appel
et pensez-vous que cette exclusion aura
des incidences sur les élections
générales en 2024 merci
merci la parole à André gatelin
maintenant
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur
d'abord merci pour votre exposé et puis
d'avoir soulevé la question des
chrétiens
d'Inde parce qu'on parle beaucoup des
chrétiens d'Orient dans cette maison et
je me rappelle quand j'ai évoqué cette
question il y a 2 ans les gens ont
découvert que il y avait 72 millions de
chrétiens dont la grande majorité était
catholique et les conditions qui vivent
donc sur la question religieuses c'est
vrai que ces systématique il y a une
seule exception que je note quand je
m'en âme c'est le bouddhisme et le
bouddhisme tibétain alors c'est vrai
qu'un travail du dalaï-lama pour montrer
combien le bouddhisme tibétain est lié à
l'hindouisme il y a je pense peut-être
la question du Ladak parce que c'est
effectivement un des éléments
stratégiques et géostratégiques de
l'Inde par rapport à la Chine et comme
la population
tibétaine est importante ça joue un
grand rôle je voulais vous interroger
aussi jeune de terminer la lecture de
Touquet le démocratie de chandlery et
Keynes que je trouve assez formidable
sur le passage despotisme et ce qui est
intéressant dans dans ce bouquin au-delà
effectivement de ce que vous avez
rappelé vous refusez d'appeler les
libéralisme et vous avez un peu raison
mais la rupture par rapport au à
l'organisation des élections aussi des
systèmes d'équilibre de justice il
ajoute un troisième facteur qui appelle
SOS la mort la mort sociale et comment
d'ailleurs il manque que ce phénomène
est antérieur à l'arrivée de maudit au
pouvoir et que quelque part ce qu'il
faisait dans une société extrêmement
pauvre et inégalitaire il y avait une
notion dignité malgré les classes et que
tout ça est en train d'exploser de son
point de vue au long cours renforcé par
l'attitude du pouvoir de maudit puis
dernier élément un sujet qui m'intéresse
beaucoup de qui est celui des influences
étrangères je suis toujours je suis
beaucoup là dans ce moment je suis assez
étonné de voir que cette influence ne
passe pas directement par les ambassades
les autorités ce sont beaucoup les
sociétés oligo holistique qui vont
financer en Europe à Paris enfin en
région parisienne notamment le premier
grand temple le plus grand temple
d'Europe continentale
d'hindouisme traditionnel et j'ai changé
avec certains de ces grands patrons qui
vivent tous à l'étranger qui vivent pas
en Inde mais alors qu'ils mettent
énormément d'argent pour valoriser
l'image ou l'influence en Inde en
particulier en France mais dans le reste
de l'Europe donc voilà si vous avez des
réactions
merci Yannick beaugrenard à la parole
maintenant oui merci président merci
beaucoup monsieur le directeur pour
votre exposé il a l'intérêt de nous
donner beaucoup d'informations et de
nous mettre aussi en appétit de
connaissance et du coup tous les sujets
peuvent pas bien sûr être évoqués il y a
un sujet que sur lequel je souhaiterais
vous questionner sur la condition
féminine en Inde et son évolution merci
monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur vraiment votre
exposé était passionnant alors moi je
souhaiterais donc poser une question qui
va nous entraîner vers vers le monde de
spatial les étoiles la lune etc puisque
depuis 1967 vous avez parlé c'était très
intéressant du plurilatéralisme je crois
qu'ils ont su s'associer et prendre donc
les différents partenaires depuis 67
avec l'URSS ils ont une très grande
politique de développement des lanceurs
à des coûts qui sont donc réduits mais
ils ont aussi beaucoup d'ambition voilà
habiter donc
Objectif Lune mais il ne s'interdise pas
donc de se préoccuper de mars et dans
justement l'évolution les évolutions
géopolitiques de ce monde et cette
course à l'espace on se rend compte
qu'ils sont forts bien placés et qu'ils
ont devancé donc beaucoup beaucoup de
prétendant et notamment ils nous ont
devancé à nous les Européens par rapport
donc à notre volonté avec l'Agence
spatiale européenne dont c'était un
petit questionnement complémentaire mais
qui je pense est tout à fait d'actualité
dans le monde de controversé que nous
vivons
c'est les dernières questions qui sera
posée par rachidman merci monsieur le
Président ce directeur moi c'est oui
c'est une forme de question parce que
alors l'Inde effectivement est un futur
géant si ce n'est pas déjà on sait très
bien les droits de Pacifique c'est un
des pièces majeures on sait bien que
c'est une pièce majeure notamment nous
pour nos notre défense même si il faut à
chaque fois donner beaucoup de choses et
donc la question c'est à quel moment ils
seront incapacité de produire par
eux-mêmes et être finalement des
concurrents d'autres notre notre
industrie militaire j'ai envie de dire
mais ça voilà après il y a un sujet qui
me tient à coeur c'est que on vous dit
assez peu enfin c'est que cet après-midi
d'extrême droite et que dans n'importe
quelle démocratie européenne ou autre
nous urgions des pétitions des demandes
de mise au banc de fait de ne pas
transférer un certain nombre d'armes ou
autre chose et c'est vrai que la
question que alors c'est pour ça moi je
suis passé une question mais en tout cas
comment expliquer ce silence
assourdissant sur une orientation
politique qui est quand même plus que
problématique Premier ministre et qui le
pire c'est que on voit bien que dans la
société si ce n'est que des discours
mais dans la société indienne il y a des
conséquences il y a des morts il y a des
il y a des quand même des pour groupes
je sais pas comment on peut plus de ça
mais tout ça existe pas juste des effets
de manche c'est une volonté
déjà Monique on va dire culturel
religieuses en qui devient une idéologie
qui donc l'un va s'aligner dessus et
donc ça pose des problèmes de choix de
vie en sachant que quand on connaît les
conditions de naissance de l'Inde on
n'est pas sans oublier qu'il y a eu
quand même quelques millions de morts au
moment où il y a eu la partition et que
ça entraîné quelques guerres entre
l'Inde ce qui est devenu ensuite le
Pakistan et même le Bangladesh voilà
donc on est quand même aussi un moment
donné un pays très puissant je
l'évoquais qui a sa tête un régime qui
peut poser de réels problèmes sans
parler bien sûr du Cachemire et de
l'Inde extra de la chimique etc enfin
tout ça bon donc voilà donc ma question
c'est plutôt comment voyez non pas ce
que le premier ministre mais en tout cas
comment ça infuse dans
est-ce qu'on peut considérer que c'est
juste le temps d'imprimer tout c'est
plus profond que ça merci merci Rachid
en fait j'ai une question supplémentaire
par huxory merci président parce que je
pensais que Rachid t'es mal allait
évoquer le sujet dont je voulais parler
Joël guerriot tout à l'heure à rappeler
un travail qui avait été effectué sur
l'Inde ensemble racheté mal gris et
moi-même quelques mois plus tard nous
sommes occupés à l'Indopacifique et
cette fois-ci nous avons eu la chance de
nous déplacer vous avez montré tout à
l'heure une une carte qui finalement se
superpose assez avec la carte de
française de l'Indo Pacifique ce qui est
un peu une particularité par rapport aux
autres aux autres pays
le fait que la France aussi se désigne
comme puissance d'équilibre sans qu'on
sache véritablement qu'il y a derrière
ces termes et que l'Inde vous l'avez
très bien expliqué soit dans le soit ne
prennent pas de position pour pouvoir
continuer à discuter et commerciaux avec
tout le monde est-ce que vous pensez que
ces différents rapprochements font de
l'Inde un partenaire fiable sur
l'Indo-Pacifique et est-ce qu'il peut
selon vous y avoir des coopérations plus
étroites sur ce vaste territoire avec
avec ce pays compte tenu de ces points
communs je vous remercie
voilà merci Hugues Monsieur le Directeur
vous avez grosso modo une demi-heure
pour répondre à toutes ces questions
mais vous serez le faire je n'en doute
pas merci beaucoup toutes ces questions
sont
[Musique]
parfaitement je dirais
pertinente et je vais essayer de le
répondre le plus précisément possible
sans dépasser l'horaire alors la
question de la population effectivement
nous conduit à celle de la pauvreté et à
celle du changement climatique la
pauvreté c'est une énorme
tâche alors avec et sans accent
circonflexe
parce que c'est quelque chose que l'Inde
cherche en permanence à éviter à éluder
Annie et puis c'est une énorme tâche
parce qu'il faut s'y coltiner quand même
nous n'avons plus les données
statistiques qui permettent de mesurer
le nombre de pauvres parce que comme je
vous l'ai dit on a plus de
d'insey à l'indienne on a un national
simple qui est l'Insee à l'indienne
qu'on empêche de travailler bon les
statisticiens sont assez courageux pour
faire le travail quand même et puis le
faire passer fuité littéralement et
quand ils ont fait fuiter leur dernier
rapport en 2019 on a vu que pour la
première fois depuis qu'il y a des
statistiques en Inde le pourcentage de
personnes vivant sous le pauvreté avait
augmenté
pour la première fois depuis 1971 que
l'on a ces statistiques on a vu le
nombre de pauvres augmenter en
pourcentage et ce à cause de la pauvreté
rurale
et ça va nous ramener à la question du
Surmont climatique d'ailleurs on a un
défi majeur l'agriculture indienne est
percutée par la croissance démographique
il faut nourrir de plus en plus de monde
c'est quand même tous les ans 15
millions de bouches en plus à nourrir
vous ajoutez tous les ans 15 millions de
personnes c'est énorme et deuxièmement
et bien on a ces problèmes d'intempéries
de de vagues de chaleur totalement
anormale et la fait 42 degrés au mois de
février à Bombay c'est sans précédent on
a eu ensuite des pluies qui n'étaient
pas du tout de mousson puisque la
mousson c'est pour juillet normalement
et ça ça pose le problème de la de la
ruralité alors c'est paysan ce sont
révoltés vous l'avez évoqué d'ailleurs
dans votre introduction parce que on l'a
oublié mais les fermiers ont fait un
mouvement de protestation qui a duré
pendant presque deux années contre les
oligarques d'ailleurs parce on voulait
faire de l'agroalimentaire et donner à
Adani et hambani les terres en quelque
sorte donc ils ont réussi à faire
reculer le gouvernement mais il continue
à protester bien sûr parce qu'il coûte
mieux la souffrir et il y a pas de move
il y a un grand programme qui avait été
introduit par le précédent gouvernement
le National
real
emploiement garantie acti et un
programme très important qui donnait à
toutes les familles Rurales victimes de
sous-emploi l'équivalent de 100 jours de
salaire minimum par an
[Musique]
vous posez ensuite l'action du
changement climatique et des
partenariats alors oui l'un des
directement frappé l'Asie du Sud en
général et la zone du monde une des
zones du monde qui est le plus direct en
frappé par le changement climatique avec
en particulier
un enjeu énorme c'est la fonte des
glaciers maliens les glaciers maliens
auront perdu un tiers de leur superficie
de leur volume d'ici 2050 ça va avoir un
énorme effet sur tous les fleuves alors
qui d'ailleurs n'irrige pas que l'Asie
du Sud de l'amour d'Aria jusqu'au Mékong
vous allez avoir en passant par l'Indus
le Gange le brame à poutre vous allez
avoir une réduction du débit de ses
fleuves qui sont à l'origine quand même
de la vie de centaines de millions de
personnes
et donc on a on a là
un enjeu que l'Inde
cherche à gérer en investissant dans le
solaire c'est le solaire sa politique
alternative avec des partenariats
français Total énergie
NJ on crée des des
partenariats alors avec gothamadani pour
la première entreprise ce qui a posé
d'énormes problèmes quand le cours de
bourse de adanis a été fondé le mois
dernier total a commencé à essayer de
retrouver une forme de sérénité qui qui
qui tarde à se concrétiser le choix des
partenaires est compliqué et on n'a pas
forcément les moyens de choisir parce
que de décider parce que le pouvoir
le pouvoir politique et lui-même proche
de certains opérateurs bon le soleil a
beaucoup d'avenir en Inde et c'est la
politique majeure maintenant le charbon
continue d'être la principale source de
production électrique 55% de
l'électricité française pardon indienne
est produite par charbon nous avons
d'ailleurs le mois prochain toute une
journée avec EDF sur la question des
émissions et de la transition
énergétique et l'Inde sera à l'honneur
et c'est intéressant de comparer le
bilan une Architec indien par rapport à
d'autres c'est une étude que EDF a mené
de façon comparative et très
très intéressante
la question qui suit et je m'excuse on
passe forcément du coq à l'âne c'est la
casse alors ces casques continuent à
jouer un rôle très important
surtout pour ce qui est de ce qu'on
appelle les intouchables ce qu'on
appelle encore les intouchables
physique qui est qui est prohibé du fait
de du stigmate le contact est polent
donc on ne touche pas ces gens et on ne
vit pas à côté de ces gens qui sont dans
les villages
cantonné a des hameaux séparés ils ont
leur puits parce qu'ils peuvent pas
venir tirer de l'eau dans le puits du
village c'est un touche habilité là
c'est quand même la grande difficulté de
la société indienne les autres castes
se retrouvent plus ou moins là on a 15%
de la société qui est à part
alors c'est une société qui a quand même
pris cette difficulté à bras le corps
lorsqu'elle a mis en place dès
l'indépendance une politique de
discrimination positive unique en son
genre parce que c'était très courageux
de dire il y a 15% d'Intouchables on les
recense dans le recensement on veut
savoir combien ils sont et on le réserve
15% des places dans l'éducation 15% des
places dans l'administration 15% des
sièges dans les assemblées élues
aucun pays au monde n'a essayé d'être
aussi volontariste
en termes
et ça a apporté ses fruits on a vu se
développer une forme de classe moyenne
intouchable
qui reste dans tout ça
le mariage reste une affaire de casse
mais en termes de classe si vous voulez
ils ont pu s'embourgeoiser entre
guillemets et faire pression pour que il
est quand même davantage de
des d'efforts en faveur de ces
catégories là
cette politique est en train d'être
remise en cause et ça va de pair avec je
dirais la dimension très conservatrice
de du gouvernement actuel on dilue cette
politique alors on la dilue
indirectement à travers les
privatisations c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
pour les intouchables
la planche de salut c'est le secteur
public parce que c'est là que sont les
quotas pour eux dès lors que le secteur
public fond comme neige au soleil et
bien la part qu'ils ont dans ce secteur
public diminuent elles aussi et
aujourd'hui vous avez du coup un retour
en arrière en quelque sorte avec une
perte de de mobilité sociale ascendante
et ça c'est une c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle
Emirats Arabes Unis Inde France oui
c'est très intéressant ce nouveau
dialogue trilatéral au moment même où
d'ailleurs le dialogue crlatéral France
Inde Australie reprend puisque après une
période un peu compliquée Anne France
Australie repart dans l'adopathie
ensemble et bien l'autre dialogue
trilatéral qui qui lui a pris forme il y
a quelques mois c'est émirat Anne-France
c'est à dire que je pense qu'on l'a vu à
travers l'écart pour les deux pays
français Indes l'Indo-Pacifique va
jusque là va jusqu'aux émirats et donc
ça fait partie d'une géopolitique qu'on
partage la France a des relations très
étroites avec les Émirats notamment du
point de vue militaire
l'Inde a des relations très étroites
avec la France notamment du point de vue
militaire ce triangle il est tiré par la
dimension stratégie-comédaire et par la
dimension géopolitique
et donc il a certainement beaucoup
d'avenir
une erreur politique que de disqualifier
Raoul Gandhi oui je pense que
je pense que naren dramaudi a peut-être
fait la première erreur politique de sa
carrière
en prenant le risque de victimiser Raoul
Gandhi
c'est une forme de perte de sang-froid
que ça reflète
on ne se débarrasse pas comme ça d'un
homme qu'on ne pense pas dangereux
franchement le prétexte est très ténu
sont des voleurs
on a entendu pire dans la vie politique
et pas qu'on Inde
à cause de ça il est condamné à deux ans
de prison à cause de ça il perd son
siège de député
pourquoi ça suscite une interrogation
était-il si dangereux que ça si les
cidreuse ça c'est que le pouvoir a des
choses à craindre des choses à cacher et
c'est c'est principalement les questions
de relation avec les mieux d'affaires
qui sont qui sont en cause donc je pense
qu'il a sans doute pas proportionné la
réplique
à l'ampleur du danger
suscitant deux choses un soupçon c'est
qu'il y a des choses à cacher et
deuxièmement
je le répète une victimisation d'un
adversaire
c'est pas une bonne chose c'est pas
c'est pas une bonne chose et du fait
c'est maudit qui est en train de créer
son adversaire en fait c'est lui qui
fabrique
son opposant en lui donnant une aura
qu'il n'avait quand même pas
pas encore en tout cas alors là bien sûr
la question la plus importante c'est
jusqu'où est-ce que ça va aller est-ce
qu'il va vraiment être confirmé dans sa
disqualification par la Cour suprême
est-ce qu'il va aller en prison est-ce
qu'il va être empêché de manifester s'il
refait un grand mouvement dans la rue
les étapes qui viennent sont très
importantes on a des élections
régionales dans cinq États qui précèdent
celles qui auront lieu dans un an
exactement
la locaba au Parlement à la chambre
basse du parlement
on va suivre de très près cette cette
chronologie mais ça peut être un
tournant
ça peut être un tournant dans cette
histoire
oui le bouddhisme effectivement est la
religion qu'on ne considère pas comme
exogène en Inde d'ailleurs le Bouddha
est présenté comme le septième avençal
avatar de vichenoux ce que tu ne la
récupération plus récente
alors c'est lié au fait qu'effectivement
le dalaï-lama a tout fait pour que les
Tibétains s'intègrent à la société
et finalement ils l'ont pas mal réussi
oui
exactement considérant que bon
bouddhisme à douille il y avait un
continuum
ce qui est pas entièrement vrai quand
même parce que les Intouchables qui
cherchent à échapper à l'hindouisme ils
vont où ils vont dans le bouddhisme ils
se convertissent au bouddhisme ceux qui
veulent vraiment sortir de la casse
c'est dans le bouddhisme qui trouve
l'égalité et pour d'une bonne raison le
bouddhisme est égalitaire c'est le seul
la seule religion sur place à ne pas
avoir reconnu la caste et appliqué la
caste maintenant vous évoquez la
question du Ladak et je pense que ça va
être une question assez compliqué en
fait parce que bon le Ladak est
maintenant occupé pour moitié par les
chinois depuis 62
a été privé de son statut d'État c'est
un territoire de l'Union qui a perdu
donc tout autonomie et les ladaki
bouddhistes font de cette
identité un levier pour récupérer de
la substance en quelque sorte dans une
zone aussi sensible stratégiquement
peut-être pas très malin d'avoir en
quelque sorte poussé un groupe à se
montrer plus revendicatif sur le plan
identitaire
on peut craindre aussi la des formes de
répression
je passe à la question concernant le
rôle des grands patrons dans dans le
monde parce que c'est une question très
intéressante
c'est vraiment intéressant le Parti
communiste chinois lui utilise les
branches du parti pour rayonner à
travers le monde où les Instituts
Confucius
l'état indien lui utilise ses relais que
sont les grandes entreprises
d'une part parce que diplomatiquement
ils sont trop petits il y a pas plus de
diplomates indiens que de diplomates
Singapouriens ils sont 800
alors avec un nombre de diplomates aussi
réduit on peut pas couvrir
dans ses mains toute la planète
oui
[Musique]
l'Indian friends life ah bah c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont si peu nombreux
c'est le close Shop
c'est vrai d'ailleurs pour toute
l'administration indienne c'est vrai
pour pour
alors du coup
le relais de puissance passe par le
secteur privé qui est de fait très bien
organisé vous avez de très belles
multinationales indiennes à les tata les
sons à la manœuvre et vous les voyez
beaucoup en Afrique par exemple pas que
la fête orientale d'ailleurs on les voit
maintenant ta taille de remporter un
marché au Sénégal pour les bus bon c'est
c'est tout là toute l'Afrique qui est
leur champ de d'exploration et puis oui
en Occident où ils sont bien sûr très
présents en Grande-Bretagne alors là
vous avez là vous avez une revanche
incroyable de du colonisé sur le
colonisateur et quand tata a racheté
Rover et qu'il a racheté Jaguar
ça a fait la une de plusieurs journaux
indiens pour la bonne pour de bonnes
raisons
maintenant
la diaspora est elle aussi
contaminée par ce virus identitaire et
on a vu à lester Birmingham il y a
quelques semaines des rixes en train
d'où et musulman qui était la réplique
de ce qu'on avait vu en Inde et et Dieu
sait si cette société britannique est
multiculturelle mais là elle atteint les
limites de son multiculturalisme
et c'est un vrai enjeu pour les
États-Unis aussi le Canada vous avez en
plus les cycles qui sont très très
militants la Grande-Bretagne l'Australie
c'est-à-dire que on on se voit on voit
combien le mode est le mode est devenu
globalisé c'est-à-dire que des questions
internes à la Cité indienne se
retrouvent aux quatre coins du monde
évidemment véhiculer par les réseaux
sociaux véhiculer par Internet on se
nourrit au même source on finit par
avoir les mêmes identités et elles sont
conflictuelles donc cette capacité
d'exportation elle a aussi des
inconvénients mais elle est très très
forte alors elle a aussi une dernière
limite les hommes de mains entre
guillemets les proches de maudits qui
ont le plus investi à travers le monde
sont justement ceux qui sont en
difficulté et c'est à nouveau
gothamadani quota Madani a acheté une
énorme mine de charbon en Australie pour
alimenter les assyries Indiennes il
vient d'acheter le port de Haïfa en
Israël
il est il est le relais incontournable
qui peut être est le maillon faible et
ça nous ramène des Raoul Candy parce que
trop investir dans une puissance
d'argent qui n'est pas entièrement
propre sur elle
c'est quand même un talon d'Achille
ensuite difficile à gérer
alors une très bonne question concernant
la condition des femmes ensuite parce
que
elle nous ramène d'ailleurs à la
démographie cette question
ce que l'on sait des recensements les
plus récents c'est que ce qu'on appelle
le sex rachio le nombre de femmes pour
1000 hommes
à certains peu augmenté mais reste
bien inférieur on a 900 je vais pas dire
de bêtises mais on doit être à
970 femmes pour 1000 hommes ou 980
femmes pour 1000 hommes bon il manque
des millions de femmes ça veut dire il
manque des millions de femmes à cause de
la
pratique de l'avortement sélectif des
des fœtus féminins
liés à la persistance de la dot parce
que et cette complètement contradictoire
il y a moins de femmes et néanmoins il
faut toujours payer pour les mariés
j'explique j'explique ça aux économistes
qui crochois rationnelles voilà bien
l'exemple que ce n'est pas la rareté qui
fait le prix
parce que il y a pas suffisamment de
femmes pour le nombre d'hommes qu'il y a
néanmoins il faut qu'elle paye pour
pouvoir avoir un époux bon donc vous
avez un énorme problème là de de type
démographique qui qui reflète un
problème social
parce que la fille est un handicap est
un fardeau
ensuite alors elle va être et ça c'est
un développement récent assez
préoccupant elle va être en concurrence
sur le marché du travail avec les
garçons et ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui
vu le chômage je l'ai pas évoqué ce
point mais il y a un chômage massif il y
a les jeunes urbains sont à 38% au
chômage en Inde
c'est vraiment énorme et les filles en
compétition avec les garçons
s'abstiennent de chercher un emploi de
plus en plus on a un taux d'emplois des
femmes en Inde comparable au
Moyen-Orient on est à 16% c'est très
très bas et donc c'est le reflet aussi
de ce statut de ce statut en retrait que
l'on s'attend à avoir
occupé par les femmes
[Musique]
les maths les conduisent à la physique
et à l'astrophysique il y a d'ailleurs
des observateurs astronomiques vous avez
des astronomiques qui remontent là aussi
au Moyen-âge et qui reste en activité
bref vous avez un tropisme scientifique
qui va les conduire à investir dans le
Haïti bien sûr dans tout ce qui est
informatique dans tout ce qui est mal
dans tout ce qui est physique et donc
dans le spatial et autant il peine à
construire des chars à construire des
tanks autant ils n'ont pas de problème
pour faire des satellites pour faire des
lanceurs de satellites pour faire des
missiles de longues portées et pour et
pour acquérir l'arme nucléaire puisque
là aussi c'est de la physique et l'ont
eu tout seul ils se leçon est tout seul
l'homme leur bombe la différence des
Pakistanais donc effectivement ça c'est
je dirais le substrat
culturel on retrouve la culture quand
même
mais le rôle de l'État n'est pas
négligeable non plus tout comme nous
avons fait le CNES et que c'est quand
même aussi grâce au CNES que la France
de Sibelle réussite dans les spatial
l'Inde a fait l'Indian space result
organization
l'État a été le pilote qui a permis ce
genre de réussite et là on a un
partenariat
CNES
[Musique]
mais qui est comme vous le dites aussi
un compétiteur parce que ils ont des
lanceurs qui mettent sur orbite
géostationnaire des satellites très
sophistiqués pour beaucoup moins cher
cariane
et c'est pas difficile et donc là vous
avez un énorme sujet ils sont en train
d'effectivement de prendre des parts de
marché surtout que les ratés récents
d'Ariane ne nous aide pas et et là la
collaboration se double de compétition
alors dernière question mais c'est pas
la moindre silence assourdissant et oui
et oui parce que nos partenariats
stratégiques et militaires ne sont
jamais débattus publiquement en France
ou des bâtons des ventes d'armes que
l'on fait à l'Arabie saoudite à l'Egypte
au Qatar d'une part
comment
non je sais bien mais vous avez pas
et je pense très important de
précisément se demander
quels sont les enceintes publiques ou la
négociation de partenariat aussi
important et de vente de technologie
sensible aussi importantes pour être
débattu car on se rend compte après coup
de l'ampleur de du lien qu'on crée ainsi
un lien insécable pour des décennies
mais votre propos effectivement est
différent la question est celle de
savoir si est-ce que Narendra maudit
lorsqu'il aura quitté la scène
permettra Alain de revenir à la case
départ
alors moi j'ai tendance à dire que le
point de non-retour n'est pas atteint
on a encore une spécivile on a encore
des des démocrates
et des gens qui veulent revenir au statu
quantais mais
chaque jour qui passe permet assez forte
de pénétrer la société et l'État de plus
en plus profondément
il y a de très nombreuses institutions
qui sont maintenant
je dirais acquises à ces forces
politiques là et les éradiquer sera très
difficile
c'était d'ailleurs et c'est intéressant
de le dire ce que ce que soulignait déjà
le gouvernement précédent qui voyait ses
forces pénétrer notamment les services
de renseignement et qui se trouvait les
mains liées
ils avaient ils avaient beau être au
pouvoir politiquement
il ne pouvait pas se reposer sur ce qui
va être sur ce qui aurait dû être un
bras armé de l'État la pénétration de
ses forces idéologiques étant déjà
quasiment achevé donc les institutions
qui sont perdus
par contre il y en a d'autres qui
peuvent être regagnés reconquises
et c'est
non seulement bien sûr
[Musique]
au gouvernement qui prendront le la
relève de l'assurer mais avant ça la
société de voter autrement quand elle le
pourra la prochaine fois et c'est là où
je le répète mais l'acte de vote n'est
plus le l'acte libre et et informé qu'il
était et donc ce biais pèse énormément
[Musique]
c'est
un problème qu'on rencontre dans
quantité d'autres pays
est-ce que si Erdogan perd le mois
prochain la Turquie redeviendra ce
qu'elle était
c'est un autre sujet et j'en suis bien
d'accord
mais on voit bien combien finalement
les parallèles sont riches
d'enseignement moi ma crainte elle est
plutôt ailleurs ma crainte elle est
plutôt dans le fait que
l'opposition ne pourra pas prendre
facilement le pouvoir et le successeur
de narindramody viendra du même parti
mais n'aura pas la capacité à gagner les
élections qu'il a aujourd'hui il est
populaire donc on vote si son successeur
vient de son parti mais n'est pas
populaire
on votera pas
et donc là on a une autre un autre enjeu
notre défi
que se passe-t-il quand l'un n'est plus
en mesure de garder au moins
cette feuille de vigne qui est le
scrutin
tous les 5 ans
et c'est pas une hypothèse totalement
farfelue car on voit qui est positionné
pour prendre la suite
amitchad à côté ministre à l'intérieur
le chef de l'auteur protège et ils n'ont
pas Laura de narini ils ne sont pas
populaires
donc c'est une question qui est qui est
qui est pertinente et qui nous oblige à
nous projeter dans le temps
je n'hésite pas à chaque fois que je
rencontre un responsable français lui
dire et que faites-vous le jour où yogi
ou amitcha devient prémictre de l'Inde
et là évidemment il y a comme une espèce
de sursaut parce que
on voit bien
que ce ne sera pas le même genre de
personnalité
c'est une dernière celle du sorry s'il
vous plaît
excusez-moi
alors puissance d'équilibre où le mot
est quand même
on préfère parler de puissance
d'initiative une puissance la France qui
peut lancer des initiatives et puis
créer les coalitions qui permettent de
les réaliser
c'est plus réaliste
c'est c'est plus européen
et européenise et la France c'est une
très bonne idée maintenant que l'Inde
soit un partenaire fiable dans l'Indo
Pacifique
c'est une question vraiment difficile
la crainte qu'on a
on en parlait d'ailleurs avec j'ai la
chance de pouvoir travailler avec
l'équipe de
Borel et avec Borel lui-même sur ces
questions justement du point de vue
d'Union Européenne la crainte qu'on peut
avoir c'est que là ne soit pas en mesure
de résister à la pression chinoise
voir ne souhaite pas résister à la
pression
le déséquilibre est énorme on est sur du
1 à 10
en termes de PNB en termes de 1 à 10 et
l'Inde dépend de la Chine pour son
commerce d'une manière considérable
c'est son premier partenaire commercial
elle dépend de l'âge de la Chine comme
nous dépendons de la Chine pour sa
pharmacie pour tant de produits
manufacturés
et deuxièmement elle est maintenant
cernée par des pays qui sont en train de
basculer du côté chinois le Népal Sri
Lanka effectivement l'Afghanistan le
Pakistan c'est fait
Bangladesh l'Alma elle est entourée de
pays qui sont de plus en plus pro
chinois
résister ça veut dire s'affronter ça
veut dire en découdre n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour c'est-à-dire que cette
carte est intéressante vous voyez toutes
les incursions que font les chinois du
côté indien
l'Inde regarde d'ailleurs
l'Inde ni que la Chine lui prend du
territoire
elle fait
l'autruche parce qu'elle n'a pas les
moyens de faire autrement alors comment
dans l'Indo-Pacifique peut-on du coup
compter sur l'Inde moi je pense que il
faut plutôt voir la dimension maritime
c'est manœuvre conjointe c'est
garde-côtes qui travaillent main dans la
main cette lutte contre la piraterie
internationale enfin l'impératrice
maritime dans cette partie de l'océan
Indien
c'est ça et puis et puis pensez
environnement gestion des océans
lutte contre la surpêche
toutes ces dimensions maritimes me
paraissent les plus porteuses là oui on
peut compter sur l'Inde
géopolitique géostratégique c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué
ça méritait bien une réponse
merci à vous Monsieur le Directeur de
nous avoir consacré 7h30
d'échanges je crois fructueux et
passionnant absolument et comme l'a dit
l'un de nos collègues je crois qu'en
fait cette matinée nous amène à avoir
envie de savoir encore un peu plus je
crois que c'est Yannick vogrenard qui a
dit ça tout à l'heure et il y a de vrais
enjeux
très volontiers et je ferai plaisir de
vous informer des réunions que nous
tenons sur le sujet et auquel vous êtes
les bienvenus ok ben écoutez au plaisir
de vous retrouver merci beaucoup merci